it happened again apple put out a brand
new iphone that impresses
everyone and a few months later samsung
takes the flagship crown away from them
and once again i want to switch but of
course i probably won't even though the
s21
is no doubt a far better phone in this
comparison i'll be skipping the specs
and focusing on the real world
differences that i noticed between these
that most people don't talk about
including two big issues with the s21
that i haven't heard anybody mention in
the areas that it
absolutely kills the 12 pro max let's
start out with the look and feel in your
hand
in our first comparison i complained
that the s21 was super
thick compared to the iphone and with
the massive camera bump
and that is true but in the real world
it doesn't feel
any less comfortable in the hand in fact
it actually feels a bit more comfortable
mostly due to it being a more narrow
phone
and even though i really like the flat
edges of the new iphones
they definitely make the new iphones
feel thicker in the hand which is why
apple had to cut down the battery
capacity to make them thinner because of
this the s21 actually feels thinner in
the hand even though it's not
and with that the matte glass on the
back feels a lot more grippy which is
probably why
it captures fingerprints so easily
whereas the iphone rejects them flipping
to the front
we have a ton of differences it is
interesting to see samsung starting to
back out from its curved screen
obsession
with the ultra model still having a
curve but less than before which does
show the bezel more
but it's still smaller than the iphone
with its completely flat display
the technically larger 6.8 inch display
doesn't actually
seem any larger because of this and its
wider aspect ratio so the iphone 6.7
inch display
actually seems larger that is once
you've used it for a while and the notch
stops being so noticeable
at this point i am over that notch that
is required for face id
especially with having to wear a mask so
often and i do know that the latest
iphone beta allows you to unlock your
phone with your apple watch which is
cool and all
but it also makes me wonder what took
apple so long and after using the s21
with this new under display fingerprint
sensor
i am finally sold that this is a way
better way to go
and i think apple knows this as well i
haven't had a single issue
with this new sensor it unlocks every
single time
it is incredibly fast and you don't have
to be really precise like you did with
the previous samsungs
jerryrig compared the sensor to the s20s
and it is
way bigger so it makes sense why we have
such an improvement
face id does have its advantages but
seeing the current rumors that the
iphone 13
may have an under display touch id and
having apple add a brand new one to the
ipad air 4 it seems like samsung chose
wisely
when they decided to go with another
fingerprint sensor instead of going with
a notch
go ahead and let me know which one you
prefer down in the comment section
below now one thing that keeps shocking
me every time i use the latest samsungs
are
the speakers wow do they sound good
i was expecting the same speakers from
the note 20 which are great
but no samsung keeps improving these
with every new
flagship phone that they put out now
they didn't get any louder than the note
20s but they do sound more rich
whereas apple traded mid quality for
more volume in the iphone 12s
let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
give me
on top of the sound quality improvements
the back of the phone has way less
vibration when listening at full volume
which was a big complaint of mine with
the s20 with that stereo sound is more
balanced which is great for watching
movies
and because of that call quality and
loudness is also great if you guys
caught our hands on comparison
i complained that hdr video looked quite
disappointing
the video looked a bit dull both in the
shadows and also in the highlights
where the iphone looked very bright and
like real hdr video
along with that the s21 would only let
me stream and 1080p
even though display was set to full
resolution whereas the iphone would let
me stream 4k
thankfully most of that has been fixed
youtube was updated a few days later and
now gives us 1440p
hdr video which is noticeably sharper
than 1080p
but still not as detailed as the
oversampled 4k
on the iphone that's if you have good
eyes
and fast enough mobile data which gets
quite interesting we'll cover that in
just a bit but the biggest difference
came from a samsung software update and
the hdr video went from a flat
dull scr looking image to what's
probably the best looking hdr
i have ever seen highlights are almost
too bright now
looking clearly better than the iphones
which was the previous best
take that and then add in the wider
aspect ratio of display
that doesn't have a big notch cutting
into your video and also the best
speakers i've heard in a smartphone
and the media experience smokes the
iphone 12 pro max
and it doesn't stop there the new super
bright 1500
display is fantastic in the sun when
using auto brightness
and it is technically sharper than the
iphone but of course in the real world
you can't really notice a difference in
detail
what you can notice is the 120 hertz
that is now
able to run at the high resolution which
is
a game changer that paired with the fast
animations
makes the s21 feel so much quicker when
you pick it up after using the iphone
and you notice it even more when going
back now the iphone's a14
is technically faster than the s21
snapdragon 88
scoring about 24 better performance in
multi-core tests and a massive 41
percent in single core
there is no doubt that apple is
absolutely killing it in the processor
space
and their five nanometer chips are way
more powerful than the competition
but does it really matter in the real
world when the chip is packed in a slim
phone no not really the s21 seemed to be
just as fast at launching applications
and because of that 120hz display
everything feels much snappier and don't
get me started about gaming which is one
of my biggest complaints about the 12
pro max
we have an insane amount of performance
from that a14
chip but when pushing it hard the 12 pro
max starts to overheat
and the screen ends up dimming to try to
keep the heat down
i had that issue both indoors and even
outdoors when it was cold
and vadim had the issue when he did the
gaming comparison against the s21 so the
iphone 12 graphics are technically 43
faster in benchmarks but in real world
use once a game for say 10 to 15 minutes
that extra performance is erased due to
thermals whereas the s21 doesn't have
any issues with thermals
due to their use of graphite thermal
pads to remove heat from the soc
this is a massive bummer on a brand new
expensive phone
and an issue the apple really needs to
fix with vapor chamber cooling
or these new graphite sheets which are
said to be even better and while we're
talking about performance i have to
mention
battery life and ram the s21 has double
the ram of the iphone but it doesn't
really matter most of the time both
phones keep apps open for
a long time and i couldn't tell a
difference in real world use
but i definitely could as far as battery
life the much larger
5 000 milliamp hour battery has the
upper hand even with the 120 hertz
enabled at full resolution
probably because of that new 5 nanometer
x60 modem and the new screen
that automatically drops down to 10
hertz to save power
and at the end of the day you get about
two extra hours of screen on time
with all the best features enabled now i
realize that i'm sounding like a samsung
fanboy
and i'm definitely not so let's get into
the few big issues
with the s21 that are alarming the first
one
is 5g data speeds when we did
our 5g speed test in our initial
comparison the iphone smoked the samsung
which didn't make sense to me after more
testing and real world use i noticed
that the s21 shows a stronger reception
in places where i typically get say 2
out of 4 bars on the iphone
the samsung would show 4 or even 5 bars
out of 5 which is awesome at first
glance
but that doesn't tell the whole truth in
wide open areas the s21's new x60 modem
is consistently faster than the iphone
for example reaching 198 megabits per
second compared to 165
testing one after another but the weird
thing is the difference between the
upload speeds
we have 70 megabit per second compared
to 39. the same thing goes for lower
signal areas outdoors with the s21
getting 43 down
compared to 20 but on the upload side
it gets less than one compared to three
what's even more interesting
is that when i'm in tougher indoor
locations like basements
the s21 shows a stronger data signal but
the speeds are actually
slower 26 compared to 46
and for upload 15 compared to 33. now
i'm not sure why this is
my only guess is that the iphone has
stronger antennas
especially with this huge cutout for 5g
specifically
but overall the iphone has noticeably
better reception in tough areas
and it has been a noticeable difference
when using the phone at my office
or at my home the other issue is low
light
photos during the day the s21 ultra
takes
amazing photos and not only with the 10x
zoom camera
which has much better quality than the
iphone's 2.5x
honestly i was shocked by how good the
software is beating out the iphone and
white balance and contrast
being much more true to life if we go
back a few years the samsung would
really struggle in this area
but now it is clearly better and we also
have a massive difference in macrophotos
thanks to that new 3x lens
that gets automatically swapped to
resulting in
fantastic macro shots overall the s21
has a shockingly good camera system
with tons of daylight detail especially
if you switch over to that 108 megapixel
mode
now my only issue with it are the
nighttime shots
specifically software where you can have
glitches that ruin photos
or at least have extra artifacts and
noise that are added
that shouldn't be there and aren't
present on the iphone we actually did a
blind camera comparison
against these two and the results were
very interesting and also very fun
so go ahead and check out the video
after this one and test for yourself
which photos you prefer without them
being labeled and the last issue that i
have with
s21 is that samsung is still limiting
manual brightness quite a bit
compared to the iphone in order to save
battery life
but i think that they should give us
full control since the battery life is
already
so good i also have to mention s pen
support since the iphone doesn't have
that
but personally i'm not a big fan of
using them even on the notes
and the s21 doesn't have a slot for it
i do have the new flip folio case that
has a slot for it on the side
but when using that case it is just so
dang wide
and uncomfortable even if you have large
hands and the last thing that i want to
quickly mention
is magsafe i definitely missed being
able to use my wallet with s21 even
though it slips off easily on the 12 pro
max
and even more so my home charger and my
in-car
charger which is super convenient and of
course i do prefer
ios and how well it integrates with the
rest of the apple ecosystem
and most of my friends and family also
have iphones so that is the biggest
thing hold me back
from switching over to samsung over say
the last couple years with all the great
phones that they've been putting out
but if you're not limited by that i
would absolutely say
go for the s21 it's definitely the
better phone overall
and if i could take samsung's hardware
and run
ios on it that would be an absolute
dream but let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below and go
ahead and click
and check out our blind camera
comparison right over there or click
above to subscribe and help us reach six
hundred thousand subs
before our two year mark in march that
would be
really awesome thank you guys for
watching this one max and i'll catch you
in the next video